- La tempête Fiona aura durement
frappé l'Atlantique,
laissant derrière
des dégats bien visibles.
Des stations-service détruites,
des poteaux électriques,
des routes bloquées.
Mais des habitants qui gardent
le moral comme George MacDonald,
qui a reçu la visite du premier
ministre de la Nouvelle-Écosse.
Quatre arbres sont tombés
sur sa maison et, par miracle,
elle est toujours debout.
L'électricité manque,
tout comme chez pl
autres résidents,
qui font la queue pour
se ravitailler en essence
pour leurs génératrices.
À Chaaux-Basques,
les dégats sont frappants.
Des maisons éventrées,
des débris éparpillés
dans la communauté.
La municipalité a ipalité a ipaé
l'état d'urgence et décrété
des évacuations.
Ces personnes ont tout perdu,
et de quoi demain sera fait
inconnu.
- Aux Îles-de-la-Madeleine,
il ne reste que des débris
du chalet familial d'Isabelle
Cormier, vieux de 40 ans.
nier, elle craignait
déjà que les tempêtes
répétitives ne l'emportent,
la mer ayant avalé les dunes
qui le protégeaient.- On est co.
À chaque année, on se dit que
c'est la dernière, la dernière,
mais finalement, on a
de la chance.
- Une chance qui a
malheureusement tourné
cette année.
Dans ce camping du sud-est
du Nouveau-Brunswick,
des propriétaires de roulotte
tentent les meubles
pendant que d'autres disent
au revoir à la leur.
- Il y a eu un pied d'eau
dans la roulotte. Probablement,
tte est finie parce
qu'il faudrait tout déchirer
l'intérieur, enlever l'isolation
qu'il y a là-dedans, et je pense
pas que ça vaut la peine.
- Fiona aura été une tempête
dévastatrice.
- Au cours des prochaines
vaillerons
avec les provinces pour les
aider à retrouver un semblant de
é le plus rapidement
possible.